seriously we're leaving in five minutes  okay well that's exactly how long it  takes me to get ready  [Music]  to the first friday night in our first  london house  [Music]  this girl is my childhood sweetheart got  me  trouble ready jesus christ  hi  why do you have so many tiny towels  they're not candy towels they're face  cloths  who's it from who do you think  i just got a boyfriend  nothing will change maggie  that's saying the thing people say when  everything's changing you have always  been my most important person i don't  know if we should be that to each other  anymore  we're in this grubby golden phase of  life that is so short-lived  sorry i want to live before i die  you